computers when I was young were super
expensive and my friend Paul Allen and I
actually snuck in two places at the
University of Washington where they had
computers that weren't being used at
night so I'm here today to release you
from the practicality of your obsession
I don't think you actually have a
passion unless you're gaining mastery in
it and you're able to alter the world in
some way through that
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation at 7:00 my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent adds something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's start your day off
right together grab your coffee and sip
on today's message find your obsession
over to you Bill Gates computers when I
was young were super expensive and my
friend Paul Allen and I actually snuck
in two places at the University of
Washington where they had computers that
weren't being used at night and so we
were fascinated by what the computer
could do but very few people were
getting exposure we had to go out of our
way and we were lucky that we did at all
and so then when the idea of moving the
computer onto a chip that Intel would
make and that would make the computer
literally millions of times cheaper than
the ones we were using so both more
powerful and available to people on a
personal level then the idea of okay it
would be very different the software you
needed the way the industry would work
we were super lucky to be there when
that was happening so what did your
family think did they say there's
something wrong with this young man he
wants to just do computers they knew I
was obsessed with computers that I would
skip athletics that I'd go in overnight
that I you know leave the house
sometimes when they prefer I wouldn't go
work at night on these things
and so it was kind of considered a
little strange and the big moment was
when I said instead of going to part of
my senior year that I wanted to go work
for company writing software so they
were great about allowing that to be my
hobby so this is a message it will come
up over and over and over and over again
if you want to have success you need to
be obsessed
whether it's obsessed or follow your
passion or find your flow or follow your
bliss all the different words and ways
people throw out it's the same thing you
got to love what you're doing you got to
be obsessed with it not just for
business but athletics music anything
you want to be a great father you have
to be obsessed with being a great father
you want to be a great wife you have to
be obsessed with being a great wife like
if you are dedicated focused you love
doing it you're spending more time on it
you're obsessed with it you will get
better it's great to hear it again I
think though what what holds most people
back is when the obsession doesn't seem
practical when you love doing something
but you don't know how it's gonna work
out and as a result of that the
practicality gets in the way and people
end up doing something practical instead
of following their obsession you go
become an accountant instead of being a
professional gamer because you don't
know how it's all gonna work out I think
that's the real danger spot and I think
if you if you study success look at the
people I've profiled in this channel or
look at your heroes a lot of times the
big dreams the big ambitions that they
had the obsession that they had did not
make sense in the beginning so I'm here
today to release you from the
practicality of your obsession release
you from the practicality of your dream
release you from it having to make sense
immediately in the present moment it
does not that's not how it works when I
first started helping out entrepreneurs
three people showed up to a free event
that I did and I thought I'm never gonna
make any money doing this that this is
the stupidest business idea in the
history of business ideas if you can
only get three people to show up for a
free event how are you ever gonna make
money from this I thought it would never
be a speaker because entrepreneurs don't
have money to pay me and no corporation
is gonna hire me to come and speak to
their audience about how to be an
entrepreneur right go leave your job and
become an entrepreneur this this is nuts
is never gonna work when I got into the
dance business I thought I'm never gonna
be a dancer why am I doing this doesn't
make any
swine learn salsa Blind become a dancer
I'm old
you know I'm take big steps I didn't
learn as a kid growing up but don't
speak Spanish it didn't make sense apart
from the fact that I loved it I loved
the process I love dancing I loved
learning how to dance
I loved helping entrepreneurs I loved
the process I love speaking I love
helping people one on one it just filled
me up and so I had to keep doing it
become obsessed with it I got better at
it and eventually as long as you keep
thinking about it how do I add value a
number one rule of money you want to
make money
you got to provide value as long as you
keep thinking about it how can I provide
value through my obsession serve others
then eventually you will even though it
doesn't make practical sense right now
when Bill Gates first started on
computers it didn't make sense
IBM was the big company it was only seen
as something that would be four giant
corporations and governments the idea of
a personal computer came to Bill Gates
it became his mission but when he first
started learning computers it wasn't a
thing even when he got to the idea of
every home needs to have a computer
people thought he was crazy but this is
this is never gonna happen you're nuts
Bill Gates but before he got to that
there were years of tinkering and
playing with computers when there was no
logical practical way that this would
ever work out except for the fact that
he loved it so we had to keep doing it
and I think that is the most critical
message that I had for you today release
yourself from the practicality of your
dream working out release yourself from
the how you don't know how you don't
know how you don't know how you don't
know how you don't know how release
yourself keep doing it keep following
your obsession become more obsessed
double down on the obsession and then in
that obsession try to find ways that it
can provide value to other people ways
that you can serve others and if you can
do that then you've just hit a home run
you will build a massively successful
business and then you can prove all
those haters wrong who told you that you
couldn't make it now I've got a really
special bonus clip for you but before
that I want to know question the day
what is your obsession right now that
doesn't make sense what is the thing
that you're doing that doesn't make any
practical sense you have no idea how
this thing is gonna work out or if you
have a story from the past that you want
to share please put down the comments
below I'd love to hear and I think also
it could inspire a lot of belief nation
is watching who might be dead in
themselves
and about to make a terrible decision
doing a save corporate job instead of
chasing a dream so please leave in the
comments thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso and enjoy the
bonus
[Music]
passion my simple model which is the
Dharma model it also dharma means
eternal duty in the Vedic tradition it's
very similar to what a key guy is being
spoken about today which is a Japanese
version of reason for being why do we
live where is meaning coming from and it
talks about an intersect of four areas
what am I good at what do I love what is
the world need and how do I get paid for
it
to me those four help you unlock your
passion when you find the intersect
across all of those four you're making
your passion your purpose you'll unlock
your passion you'll find your purpose
this is path one there's two paths path
one I find my skill set and I engage it
to help other people and become better
at it so I'm becoming better at what I'm
good at and I'm using it to help other
people because I'm aware of what I'm
quite good at and I know what more
knowledge I have what skills I have I
have some self-awareness the other path
that people often miss is actually I
just start serving people I just start
helping people and I start to notice
what I enjoy about that and what I'm
good at helping people with so that's
Gandhi's part Gandhi said that you find
yourself when you lose yourself in the
service of others so for me those are
the two paths of how do I find my
passion and finding the intersect
between those four areas here is how I
actually have experienced the world so
passions are created they are not innate
it's not something that's born within
you might walk people through how I
developed my passion for film before
I've walked people how I developed my
passion for the body and helping people
with nutrition so I won't belabor that
point now but just know that it is
something that you create it starts with
an area of interest you engage with that
interest it either gets more interesting
to you which I'll call a fascination or
a doesn't if it doesn't move on to
something else find another area of
interest engage with it and see if it
grows an interest and the easiest way to
understand that is as you engage with as
you spend more time with it is it giving
you more energy than it takes so if it
gives you more energy and you feel alive
and you look forward to and you want to
do it that's a very good sign that this
is something that's leading towards a
real fascination now in the book so good
they can't ignore you Cal Newport really
differentiates between the classical
view of a passion which is like I was
born with it I'm on fire and it's just
naturally amazing
what I think is actually a passion which
is the act of gaining mastery takes a
deep fascination and turns it into a
passion but I think like love is a
reciprocal relationship and you're not
actually in love if there's no
reciprocity I don't think you actually
have a passion unless you're gaining
mastery in it and you're able to alter
the world in some way through that
whether it's a musical creation whether
it's becoming an incredible teacher and
you know that you're impacting people's
lives whatever it is your skill set
actually allows you to serve other
people and that emotional resonance of
going wow I worked really hard for this
skill set I am actually good at this
thing and being good at this thing
actually allows me to manifest that in
some way that is tangible in the real
world now terrific world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think unseen
it's a bloody brief life all of you have
the potential for enormous success if
you want to know what gary vee DJ khalid
oprah and others know about empire
building that most people miss check out
the link in the description for a free
bonus video